[MUSIC PLAYING]
JINAL DALAL: Good evening--
hi.
I'm going to present electronic
design for Android Things
Systems on modules.
My name is Jinal Dalal.
I'm a hardware engineer
for Android Things.
And I'm really
excited to present
to you this particular
talk, especially
because I built hardware for
Google for about 10 years.
And I built for
consumer and enterprise.
So everything that you
see here are the things
that I've learned over
the past 10 years.
And please don't repeat
the same mistakes.
All right, let's get started.
So before I get into the details
of how to build hardware,
Android Things has
System on Module,
which is the core component
of Android Things, which
has CPU, memory, power, as
well as Wi-Fi and Bluetooth.
This is the core component
of Android Things, which
allows you to take all the
complexity out of your hardware
and put the wrapper around it.
So going into the
detail, this board
is about 2 inches by 2 inches.
And it, basically,
is something you
can buy off-the-shelf today.
So if you were to
think of an idea
that you want to build using
this as the core module,
you don't have to go
out and design it.
And all the technical
complexity around this
has been taken away from it.
As far as this particular
talk, the thing
that we built
internally into Google,
in a very simplified
way, is the baseboard.
This is the board
that goes with the SoM
and allows you to add
more functionality to it.
So imagine use cases like
cameras, routers, and displays
that would like to use the
SoM as the core component.
It's the baseboard that you end
up designing for your solution.
In this particular
case that I designed,
it had USB ports, audio,
HTML, buttons, LEDs.
So this is something
you can design.
This does not require a whole
team of hardware engineers
to go out and design it for you.
And I'm going to walk you
through those steps of how
to actually do those things
as part of this talk.
All right, before jumping into
the details of hardware design
again, Android Things
joins this group
of Android platform, which are
about 2 billion devices that
exist today.
As well as, it takes advantage
of the Android framework,
so it allows you to use
what you already know.
For example, even in cases
of cars, TVs, watches,
and wearables, as
well as cell phones--
you're already familiar
with these platforms.
And now, you're using this to
build IoT devices around it.
From the ideas perspective
and from what this enables,
there are a bunch of options
to go out and design.
In terms of home, you can
think about security systems,
speakers, routers, doorbells.
For enterprise--
point-of-sale, interactive ads,
vending machines.
I'm going to share
some examples of that.
And for more of building
and enterprise buildings,
it's cameras,
[INAUDIBLE],, smart meters.
And for cars and
fleet management,
you could think about
smart parkings, car audios,
and so on.
The opportunities are endless.
There will be about 20
billion devices by 2020.
And so this really opens
up the whole opportunity.
In terms of hardware,
how many of you
here have actually
designed hardware
or been part of the design?
So having realized a few
of them, this is really--
we're at this point where
hardware is really not
about different or hard.
It's more about how you
actually go through the process
to build it.
So as much as how
software is built,
hardware is built differently.
But the focus should be, really,
on making those small steps
to get you to the right platform
and to the more solid hardware.
So there are three things that
have happened in the past,
I would say, five years that
have phenomenally changed
the way hardware is built.
One-- there are 3D printers.
If you think about a box or
a photo frame or anything
that you would like to
design, you can actually
go print it out today.
This plus the IoT platform
that we are building
would enable you to build
a product around it.
Secondly, there
is crowdsourcing.
And third, is the cost of
manufacturing-- all these three
things allow you to
experiment with the ideas
without actually needing a
big team to go out and do it.
Again, going back
to this example,
this along with the wrapper
took us one person at Google
to go out and build it.
These are just two
general examples
of what you can do with
the existing solutions.
For example, a vending machine
that doesn't have a display
can start using display and
a phone for its check-out.
And with this Android
Things platform,
you are able to actually
experiment with it.
As well as the pill
dispenser, again,
allows you to manage the
schedule for the pills as well
as notifications
and so on-- again,
making something that's
been there for a while
and making it smart.
So before we talk about
the process again,
this is the board that
I was just showing you.
The red is the baseboard
that I designed.
The green is the
System-on-Module
that sits on the baseboard.
As you can see, this
was for an XP device.
So the SoM is
actually an XP device.
But the baseboard is flexible.
It allows you to add any
features that you would
like to use for your product.
All right, so process--
the first step for hardware
design is planning.
Planning really means
identifying the core components
and features that
you want and then
sketching it out on paper to
figure out how it all connects.
Second is prototype.
Prototype is about actually
buying off-the-shelf hardware
and implementing it
as an experiment.
Third is design.
From a software standpoint,
design is making the UI.
From a hardware
standpoint, you're
really getting into
the nitty-gritty
of using the schematic
tools, the layout tools,
as well as releasing
those for manufacturing.
And last is qualify.
Each of these steps really
needs to be followed
and are really critical for
the success of your design.
And it needs to be
repeated to ensure that you
can keep building more volumes.
So let's go into
the detail for plan.
Planning, from the
hardware standpoint,
is really-- one, identifying
the features that you want.
So you want USB support?
You need a USB connector.
If you want audio, you need
to add audio connector.
If you want to use a display,
this, again, needs to go here.
It's critical to actually
sketch your design up
before you start
implementing it.
This is a critical step.
And you need to think about
all the features, as well
as the rest of the things,
which is power and size.
So this is in a
different dimension.
Think about how hot this
product is going to get.
Where is it going to be used?
Is it going to need cables
from your product standpoint?
Beyond that, also
think about the cost
very early on, so
that you don't end up
buying components that are
expensive from the beginning.
And then finally, how
is it all powered?
Is it a battery powered or AC?
This also matters in the design.
So that's the planning piece.
Next is prototype--
I want to emphasize
the value of prototype.
When you start thinking
about your design
and you think that you need
to wait all the way until you
actually design everything
in schematic and layout,
it's already too late.
And you already spent thousands
of dollars to get there.
So before you do that, try and
see if you can buy components
online.
Put it on the breadboard.
Connect wires.
And get your basic
functionality in place.
Again-- I'm going to repeat--
get your basic functionality
in place as much as possible,
so you know exactly what you
are using, how you are using it,
how much power does it draw,
and even to the extent that--
how does it look?
If you can 3D print
something or use a cardboard,
it's worth trying it.
Because by the time you
get it to the production,
it's going to be too late.
Design-- this is something where
most of the software developers
are going to be challenged, in
terms of how to actually start
implementing the schematics.
Fortunately, again,
in the last few years,
there are a lot of
open source options
that you can use to start
sketching out your design.
As an example, a key CAD
is an open source schematic
and layout tool that you
can use today with no cost
and try a simple board.
There are a few other
options as well,
from Altium, Cadence, and Eagle.
And each one has its
own pros and cons.
For example, depending on
how many layers the board is
or the cost that you're
willing to pay for this tool,
each one has its own trade-offs.
In my particular case,
we ended up using Altium,
mostly because
it's what I knew--
as well as what I was trying
to build, which was an 8
to 10-layer board.
All right, let's
dig a little bit
deeper into what a
schematic really is.
So from a hardware
standpoint, the schematic
has a 2D representation
of your design.
Every component
that you can think
about that's going
to be on your board
needs to be on the schematic.
As you can see over onto
the screen, on the left side
is the capacitors.
That's marked as C1, C2, which
are the reference designators.
The one in the
yellow are generally
ASICs or connectors,
the components that
are tied to these components.
There is ground,
which is represented
by the lines, which represents
the ground of the board.
There is the power, which is
the input to your circuit.
And then all of these
traces that you see
are all your connections.
They're physical
traces that are going
to be populated onto the board
to make these connections.
After you are finished
your schematic,
the next step is to
start doing the layout.
Layout is, in some sense,
a 3D representation
of what your design is.
You start thinking about
where the components go
physically on the design--
how they are routed.
Not going into too much
detail, but this hardware
is tied to physics.
And so how do you run your
single-ended and differential
pairs, like clocks and signals,
are critical in the design.
And this is where you can
leverage either some help
from online schematic
or data sheets
or work with somebody you know.
But this is where you need
to spend some time thinking
about how your
board needs to look,
where the key
components need to go.
This is what the board's
layout looked like.
And this is just
one of the layers.
There were eight
years on this board.
The traces are the lines that
you see going from the top
to the bottom--
are essentially
the physical traces
that have been routed
to a connector.
The yellow, I would say, text
is reference designators.
And if you care about how you're
going to debug this board,
you need to ensure that these
things are placed properly.
Similarly, some of the
symbols represent where
the components need to go.
Once you're done
with the layout,
the next step is to see
what exactly it looks like.
And this is pretty cool.
In hardware, you can
actually start, not only
thinking about what you are
trying to build but also
feel and see what it is.
And this is very things
get really exciting.
You need to take the
time to actually look
at where your components
are in this framework.
For example, are my
buttons in the right place?
Is LED accessible?
Are the connectors
accessible for connecting?
This is where you can physically
check every single thing
to make sure that they're
lined up properly.
For example, one of
the issues that we
found when we were
designing this board
is the LED was actually
placed in the back.
And so it wasn't
visually possible
to see the LEDs from the
front when they are blinking,
especially for error LEDs.
So it's important, again,
to think about these
as part of your design.
After you are done with
this, what happens next
is really taken over by
the manufacturing company.
But what you need to send
them is the Gerber files.
Now, if you don't know
what the Gerber files are,
Gerber files are or a
software text presentation
of each of these components,
the size of the board,
the traces, the holes that need
to go onto the board, as well
as all the connections.
This is a file that
you then send over
to your manufacturing
company, who then ends up
building it for you.
It's important for them to
not only check this for you,
but this is also
something that they
will help you confirm
that they received
all the right information.
A critical step in
this process, even
though it might seem simple--
in my case, there
was an instance
where they received the files,
but they were corrupted.
And they couldn't actually
built the right board--
so expensive and
important step that you
need to pay attention to.
In terms of manufacturing,
there are two options today,
which is really great,
in terms of the cost.
And there are
trade-offs for each one.
One is local.
Once your board is ready,
you have your Gerber files,
you could release it
to somebody locally.
Either it's US or
somewhere else,
which generally costs higher.
And here are a few examples
of companies you can use.
Or you can do it offshore.
There, the trade-off
is the cost is cheaper,
but it also takes
much longer time
for you to receive your boards.
Key takeaways for
manufacturing-- one,
test every board.
It is important that
you're building your board
for the first time.
Do not make the assumption
that it's the replica.
And it's just going to work.
You have to test every
single board that comes out
of the line for the first time.
Two, visually inspect before you
actually start powering it on.
There was an instance where
I had the capacitor reversed.
And as soon as I plugged in
the power, it actually blew.
And there was real fire.
So this is real.
You got to pay attention
to your design.
It does matter how careful
you are before you actually
turn on the power.
In turn, if possible,
don't wait until the boards
are shipped to you.
Go to the factory, if you can.
See as soon as they come out.
And make sure that
they work as intended.
There have been instances
where, by the time they reach--
after 10 to 15 days,
you might find a bug.
And now, it takes another
set of changes and time
before you can get
this error corrected.
Versus in software-- you can
just do it in a few seconds.
All right-- once you have your
board, you've received it,
you've checked for
key components,
whether they have been
populated properly or not--
the next step is to debug.
If you have some
basic e-skills, you
can use a multimeter
to check your signals
and see if they are wiggling.
You can use a scope,
if you have one.
But really, the key
message here is, try
and debug as much as possible.
I'll give you one example here
that is not obvious to you.
But or on the right
side for you, the one
that is marked as D is a Diode.
And what we realize, as part
of our manufacturing process,
is that the diode was
actually the worst.
And this diode actually
serves as D card--
as D card wasn't detected.
Again, visually
really hard to see.
But this ended up being a bug in
our design, where the diode was
placed reversed and
ended up causing
us a No Detect for the SD card.
Thermals-- I'm briefly
going to touch on thermals.
But this is an important aspect
of the hardware design as well.
So you would assume that, if the
hardware works on your table,
it's going to work on your desk.
It's going to work
everywhere else.
That's not true.
As soon as you start
bumping up the temperature
on the hardware, you will start
seeing all kinds of issues,
from shut down to heating
up some components
and causing fire.
It's important to think
about the critical components
in your design and
make sure you meet
the guidelines and the operating
specs of those components.
If you can detect, in
this particular case,
I have a heat sink for the CPU.
And initially, based
on our experiments,
we realize that a heat
sink may not be required.
After trying a few
experiments on the desk,
as well as in a
thermal chamber, we
realized that this was
required to operate
the CPU at a particular
temperature range.
Again, a small thing
in this design--
got to pay attention to it.
Lastly, mechanicals-- after you
have done your hardware design
and finished the design
for it, the next step
is what the
enclosure looks like.
With 3D printing, you can print
something out and test it out.
Critical here is to look
for all the instances
where you're going to
interact with your design.
If there is a button,
make sure it's accessible
and it's in the place
where you want it to be.
If it is LEDs, you
should be visually
able to see them from what
is expected out of it.
Similarly, for connectors, make
sure that they're not locked.
It's always worth experimenting
and printing something out
or use a cardboard to make
sure that the e-components are
in its place before you
go to the next step.
In terms of mechanicals,
there are two options
to actually design it.
One is called soft-tooling.
And the other one
is hard-tooling.
In soft-tooling-- this is
where the cost is higher.
The turnaround time
is, again, shorter.
And it is really designed
for limited-use cases.
So if you expected the lifetime
of a product to be three years,
a part that is soft-tooled
might last only a year.
A hard-tool is where you
actually use the sheet metal
and use a hard-tooling
solution to build your product.
This is higher cost.
There is a high NRE associated
with it, a slower turn around--
used mostly for
high-volume products.
And it's designed for the
full life of the product.
When you buy
consumer electronics,
most of the tooling
is hard-tooled.
While all the
experimental hardware
that you have internally
or at your desk,
for example, might
all be soft-tooled.
OK, finally, qualify--
I think, after you have finished
all the aspects of this design,
you've got to qualify your
product from end-to-end,
in terms of software.
So bring the hardware up.
Run all the software
on top of it.
And make sure the
design is solid
and all the features are
meeting your expectations.
And set up a password
criteria for them,
so that you know what's going to
happen if certain features are
turned on and off.
This finishes the cycle
from plan to qualify.
And in some ways, you would
think that you are done.
Not yet-- take this
process that I just showed.
And if you are trying to
build a product that's
going to be thousands
of units, you
need to move on to the
next phase, which is
what I'm going to go through.
So EVT is the Engineering
Validation Test.
The whole process
that I just showed you
needs to be repeated for EVT.
Generally, EVT is
about tens of units.
And the goal here-- to validate
your schematics, your layout,
your design, the core features,
the components on the board,
and ensuring that it all works.
It is not necessarily designed
to run all the software that
is expected at the end product.
The cost for EVT is high.
So in some ways, you would think
that the cost of the product
is going to be high.
But that's not necessarily true.
There are a few reasons why
the cost for EVT is high.
One, it's low volumes.
Two, it is manufactured
in a very controlled way.
So there is a high
cost associated
from an NRE standpoint.
And then, three, the
components that you buy
are also going to be limited.
And so that's going to
keep your costs high.
Next, is DVT.
DVT is the Design
Validation process,
where you validate the
design and also involve
some of the software
teams into your platform.
This is also where you
test our software bugs.
And generally, you
find the issues, which
are 10% of the total yields.
So pay attention to
those, fixing those,
and then ensuring that
you are ready to move
onto the next stage.
In terms of the cost
for a DVT platform--
is about a few
percent more than EVT.
The cost is, again,
driven by the cost
of the board, the
components that you select,
as well as the process
that you are using.
Finally, PVT is the
Production Validation Test.
This is generally in
thousands of units.
And you need to ensure
that the manufacturing line
that you have is set up to
handle the volumes that you're
projecting.
This validates that process
as part of this step.
In terms of the issues
that you find-- are the 1%.
Imagine now, you're
building thousands of units.
And so you're going to
catch those small bugs that
happen in the
hardware, which you
wouldn't have found otherwise.
The other focus is
really on ensuring
that the process and the line
is set up to go really high.
Cost-- the cost for
PVT is generally
less than 1/2 or even 1/3
of what the cost of EVT is.
This is really where the
high volume kicks in.
Along with that, the tooling
is going to be hard-tooling.
So that means that
you're going to start
using a much better design
solution for your product.
Finally, mass production--
mass production
is where you are going to start
selling your units to your end
customers.
This is going to be
thousand of units.
And this is where
you start, also,
qualifying your
second sources, where
you start adding new components
to your design to reduce cost.
And the yields are
going to be critical.
So pay attention to how
your product is performing
in the factory, especially
for those small percentage
of failures that you are seeing.
This step is really where
the real cost comes in.
This is generally, like
I said, less than 1/3
of the cost of an
EVT or even lower.
And you can further push
it by using second source,
optimizing your
processes, even changing
some of the design, in terms
of the components that you
have selected, and reducing the
cost, or even removing them.
Finally, you would
think you are done.
Again-- not yet.
There's a bunch
of tests that are
required for you to meet
before you can ship out
to your customers.
And each country has its own
set of compliance tests--
EMI and EMC tests, which
is critical to the product,
and of course your
software qualification.
So let's try to wrap this up.
You did the planning.
You did the prototype.
You did the design.
And then you did the qualify.
These four steps
need to be repeated
in each of these EVT, DVT, PVT
and mass production phases.
And each of these
steps are designed
to de-risk your hardware,
as I mentioned earlier.
If you take these steps
and follow it through,
most likely your
design will not have
issues that would cost
thousands of dollars.
That's the end of this talk.
There are a bunch
of things around.
If you haven't checked out
the Android Things demo,
you can go check it out.
There's Cold Labs.
And there are also a
few other presentations
from Android Things team
that you can check it out,
and a scavenger hunt.
If you haven't tried this
yet, you should try it.
You can end up getting
your [INAUDIBLE]..
And I would love to
get your feedback.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]